this is kind of a Ben feingle type thing
I saw this maybe years ago like Ben I
think the site is actually inspired by
Ben right can we watch the Youtube video
this is something people have a lot of
trouble with
the better you are at chess the better
you are at this which doesn't even make
any sense because it's very little chest
skull involved
um but you guys have very little chest
skills now let's see what the issue is
you've probably seen this before
possibly on my stream I saw this video
before but I'm re-watching it so this is
a puzzle where you're trying to move the
the person who showed this to me showed
this to me in December of 1988. wow you
moved the knights every Square on the
board
okay and you go here first and then here
and then here and then here and then
here and then here and here and then
this is the last square based on what I
just said
and the true black never moves and the
two rules are the knight's not allowed
to move to a screen a screen to a square
the queen attacks yes which means it
skips here skips here skips here okay
and and you can't take the queen
so this is the first Square so you go
here okay then this is the next Square
so you go you move like a knight you
skip this Square because the queen
attacks it you can't do this because the
queen attacks that so you have well okay
so you have to okay I think we get the
points
um if people didn't understand that
you have to avoid the screen
you can't get eaten by the screen so
this is a site which someone shared a
few days ago
that basically tests your ability to do
this
so basically the Knight has to reach f8
and then C8 and then B8 G7 all the way
through I think the final Square will be
A1
and it's all about maneuvering the
knights and not not plundering the Nike
various so I thought this would be
interesting like as as a chess player
that has spent
okay not as long as Ben Feingold but
I've spent a couple decades playing
chess
um knowing how the horse he moves
um we'll see how this how long this
takes
uh
so let's jump into it night
I think I just started and then the time
should start ticking right
oh it's ticking okay f8
there you go now E8
uh oh dear so I have to move here
wait let me just try and do this as
quickly as possible
um
E8 now C8
so E7 G6 okay
and now B8
can I get through
how do I get to B I need to get to B4
now each seven
and G7
it's not easy
C7
[Music]
A7
how do I get to A7 I need to go via C8
okay
H6 ah
this can be frustrating
ah
I think I I plungered it once but it
should be okay
it doesn't penalize me I don't think
G6
it's all about the speed
at six
now B6
all right how do I get to B6
via A4
A6
H4
oh wait
and now G4
H2 I'm getting closer ah
ah I blundered it again but that's okay
K E1 C1
B1
and then A1 let's go okay
I uh
I got less than three minutes I think
there were a couple moves I uh
I left it hanging but it just prevents
me from playing those moves
so I'm actually curious like how
how people would fare with this
if there's any like new chess players
watching that knows
of course most people know how the horse
he moves but how difficult this would be
for other players
so I'll leave a link in chat if people
want to try this
um this might be its own YouTube video
this will probably be its own YouTube
video
so actually if you're watching in the
future on YouTube
I'll leave a link in the video
description
and yeah let me know if you're able to
like do the whole thing how long it
takes
how you feel about something like this
and uh and yeah I hope I hope this
content was interesting